Joyce is with us in Phoenix Arizona hi
Joyce how are you hi I'm good thank you
for taking my call sure what's up I have
had a credit card for I would say two or
three years that does the cash back so I
always use it for gas and groceries and
and big purchases and just for the cash
back and I've always had the money in my
checking account so I would pay it off
every month I've never paid any interest
at all and so it was nice to get it like
an extra twenty thirty dollars cash back
every month to me that was like extra
spending money um but since I started
listening to you the past few weeks or
so now I feel guilty even though I've
paid it off every month I feel like oh
my gosh am I missing something that is
gonna bite me later that maybe I just
don't know about so I kind of just want
your permission and keep it and if you
say don't then I'll stop well you're
grown-up you don't need my permission
you can do whatever you want to do we
don't recommend we don't recommend that
people have credit cards as you know
from listening to me and I don't have a
card and I haven't had a credit card in
decades and and the reason is pretty
simple
okay you know have you ever known
somebody that smoked cigarettes for 60
or 80 years yeah and you know cigarettes
kill you right you know that right yeah
but that one got it that guy got away
way that he didn't kill him but he died
he died of something else or she died of
something else right you know my I have
a relative that used to say he goes yeah
he goes I drink beer every day and I
smoke cigarettes every day and a ripe
old age of 90 it's gonna kill me you
know I mean he you know and you know he
was joking but he really wasn't because
something else killed him right it
wasn't it wasn't that he got him and so
it just that didn't catch up with him
and you could you could be that person
with a credit card because credit cards
pretty well the cigarette of the
financial world everybody knows it's
stupid but a lot of people still do it
and it's some people still think it's
cool and but most people that are in
most people that are knowledgeable
realize that they're pretty stupid and
so you know the $20 that you're getting
here or there
is exposing you to you know all kinds of
possible problems and I've just never
met anybody that became a millionaire
with their cash back right you know
instead I've met a lot of people in 30
years of doing this they got themselves
in trouble and you know the an emergency
comes up and then all of a sudden you
know for two years or three years I paid
it off every month and I've always had
the money and then never use it unless I
paid it off and I've been disciplined
but then all of a sudden something comes
up and then boom there's four thousand
dollars sitting on that thing and it
starts a pattern that breaks down and
it's easier to just not play with snakes
there are people that can play with
snakes and not get bitten and you might
play with snakes for twenty years and I
get bitten and then one of them kill you
you know and so you know it's just it's
the same thing and so I just don't
there's no upside the $20 isn't an
upside that's a joke
you know there's no upside the only the
only thing you gots a downside so I
don't see any reason to have them the
debit card does everything the credit
card old it has the exact same fraud
protections and if you're paying it off
anyway you've already got the money so
it's not you know just use that the only
thing you're getting here is the cash
back and you you know we've established
that that's not gonna make you wealthy
and certainly hasn't already we know
that so that's my answer you can do
whatever you want to do though Joyce
you're a grown-up but that's what I do
and what I teach people to do hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show